we're going off to the magnetic
resonance imaging Center which is a few
hundred yards up the campus because
through Brady I've got an opportunity to
see an MRI machine I never seen one and
I really want to see how it works and
actually see what it feels like to go
inside one
this is the seven
system so it's the it's the strongest
human imaging system in the UK
one of the main inventors sir peter
mansfield worked here in Nottingham and
won the 2003 Nobel Prize for medicine
one of the few Nobel Prizes that has
recently been won by a university in the
UK and so we're extremely proud of MRI
as a technique that started in
Nottingham and has gone all over the
world so was Ashley's positioning Martin
so his head inside the RF coil the
sensitive coil that detects the signal
that we used to make the images also I
guess making sure that he knows how to
communicate with us in case he wants to
get him mate get in touch what's he's
being scared
with most magnets there's there's no
sensation it's all with a very strong
one like this one some people feel a
little bit dizzy when they just go into
the magnet but it's seen passes so we
push people in slowly to try and avoid
that
dizziness as much as possible
okay we're going to start yes I'm ready
to start okay we're gonna start
[Music]
so what we do is we're looking at
signals that come from hydrogen nuclei
inside water molecules inside the
patient in this case Martin's brain so
each hydrogen nucleus when we put some
into a very strong magnetic field like
this system then hydrogen nuclei tend to
line up with the field will you be able
to hold that for 18 minutes
[Music]
so this is like a hydrogen nuclear
magnet so we can imagine this is the
North Pole this is the South Pole so
normally in as we're sitting here the
nuclear magnets are kind of randomly
aligned or pointing in sort of different
directions but when we place someone
into a strong magnetic field the nuclear
magnets tend to line up with the
direction of the applied field which
actually in this system is horizontal so
I should prove it that way around get in
here the idea is that these these
nuclear magnets have a property that
when they get disturbed from being lined
up with the field they tend to process
around it and the rate at which they go
round depends on how strong the magnetic
field is so in this system seven Tesla
system they go round it's about a at 300
million times per second at 300
megahertz that sort of frequency is in
the radio wave region of the
electromagnetic spectrum and so there's
an interaction naturally between the
hydrogen nuclear magnets and radio waves
so the way we excite them and make them
process is by firing a pulse of radio
waves into it in this case Martin's
brain and then we get back from the
nuclear magnets a kind of echo of radio
waves produced by that procession of the
net' nuclear magnetization so what we do
to make a picture is to make the
magnetic field a little bit different in
different places in the person's body
then the frequency of precession is
different and the frequency of the
signal is different from different
locations so for example if we make the
magnetic field vary along the axis of
someone's body then we can say that a
high field occurs at the top of the head
a low field at the bottom of the head so
when we see a high frequency signal we
know it came from the top of the head
when we see a low-frequency signal we
know it came from the bottom of the head
and we can therefore assign the signal
to position
yeah it really still it was great fun
but the noise is very loud but it's it
stops very subtly the almost
disappointment so I'm going to take this
did I keep stage today so how can you
see the iron if you're looking at the
wall time we can we sensed it to the
presence of iron and what is sort of
dull kibitz thing
this we don't really associate it with
you and it doesn't look like me does it
to you so can you tell I'm left-handed
man look in the back
[Music]